- I hate being cold.
Like I'm from the desert
and cold is just not
something that I'm into.
- I actually have kind of
like a achy, bruised knee,
and I'm really hoping that
it's gonna magically fix it.
- My biggest fear would be like my fingers
getting really cold, and like falling off.
- I went skydiving before.
I think I can do this.
(techno music)
- So basically, what you
guys are gonna be doing today
is you're going to be gonna
be going into a chamber.
It's negative 220 degrees.
Some risks associated with this
could be frostbite, skin
burns and irritations,
but, we don't let you
go in for long enough
for that even to happen,
so we're gonna put you in
for a safe amount of time.
It's a minute-and-a-half.
A minute-and-a-half sounds
like a very short time,
but it'll be the longest
minute-and-a-half of your life.
- I honestly feel like I'm
in line for a roller coaster.
- Ready.
- Oh, she's ready.
- Well, I'm getting naked for a video.
- Just another day at work.
What if I pee my pants while I'm in there?
- I was literally just thinking that!
(dramatic music)
(screams)
- [Voiceover] 10 seconds.
- You know what? This
is no big deal, guys.
Oh, is it getting colder?
- [Voiceover] I'm gonna turn it on now.
- Oh, he's turning it on now.
- [Voiceover] I'm joking.
- Is it cold yet?
- Oh, my goodness, it's so cold.
- I don't think I've ever
been this cold in my life.
- [Voiceover] Oh, my gosh.
- It's so cold.
Okay, oh my god.
- Very cool.
So now we're going into the Cryo M3,
which is the meat locker version
of the cryochamber.
- The cold happens in here, actually.
When you open this door, you get welcomed
by this big cloud of cold air.
Again, minus 220 below.
So, who's first?
(dramatic music)
(scream)
- That's a human test.
- There was something nice and comforting
about being in there.
- Oh, yes.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I can kinda feel the
mucus in my nose crisp up.
Hello, Clarice.
That was cool. I liked that a lot.
(scream)
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one.
Time is up. Please exit the chamber.
- I can't speak, my brain's frozen.
There she goes.
- [Voiceover] Oh, my god!
Oh, my god!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
It's so cold.
- I think we all know who the wuss is.
- It's so cold.
- [Voiceover] This one
or the other one worse?
- I think this one.
- Usually I can't touch my toes.
Bingo, that's cryo.
Being outside in Boston
in the winter for an hour
was worse than being in there
for a minute-and-a-half.
- It was by far the coldest
that I've ever been in my entire life.
- It was definitely
invigorating and refreshing.
- I would do it again, I mean if
I see a change or feel
a really big difference
I would definitely want to come back.
So, maybe this weekend.
(techno music)